Harvard University 1976 he worked at
Harvard University as a historian until
19 and delayed and currently is the
director of the velocity Center for
reply and historical research that we
cannot intensity for different studies
at the University of Alberta Canada for
this semester he is a visiting scholar
heroin in CP calanka keeping published
extensively wrong
Ukrainian and partly of course of the
Polish topics is a competitor of the
first one disorder of applying rules and
editor of the eighth volume of this of
this magnificent addition on the Casa
age he also published on the UK and
coming on the union of breast final push
st and up chemistry but probably
most interesting for us also is also the
author of the biography of Adam TCM and
I think between Poland and Ukraine that
was published 95 so professor cannons
just mark will have these papers
presentations for each 30 minutes for
mr. chairman ladies gentlemen colleagues
and friends it's a great pleasure like
always to be at Columbia I feel very
good here and it is wonderful to see so
many people interested India teens at
the subject which we are coming to
discuss it seems to me that once one is
asked to talk for 20 minutes about three
centuries of rather rich relations Molly
has to make a very very strong hard
choices and before there are only three
topics I like to mention today one is
what we could look to to back looking
backwards to our history which may be
very useful today but second i have to
mention as a kind of memento mori a fact
that whichever way one looks at said
polish ukrainian relations in time of
commonwealth one has the feeling that
pose make very many to put it mildly
mistakes and that after 19 and 20
century not very many times they learn
from that mistakes and let's hope that
now is different and the last point if i
have time in that 20 minutes i would
like to mention just mentioned very has
a few hesitant remarks on church as that
relation of indy which will be
different religions different
hierarchies we're not we're important in
the relation of poland and ukraine and
that probably is the only field which
today still they are very or maybe
somewhat maybe not very but somewhat
similar I just think simply about the
practical physical existence now on
Ukraine indeed of the latin church now
in which falls play very important role
so to start the point which probably for
me is the most interesting from all of
those three i mentioned it's a point
connected with presence of europe in
relation of poland and ukraine or rather
in history of both country through
centuries that is i don't think it is
particularly novem to anybody to realize
how strongly